raise your hand if you manage to find a
property that's given you 28 percent or
higher yeah I just don't believe you
it's simple it will be in groups of
three and you've got to swing a hundred
pounds each everyone I'm Jamie Jamie way
from Jamie Shepard London you're from
London
all right awesome see if your mind works
this time cuz you might work I just
grabbed Jamie's mic oh that one
alright what's your name Chris it's
Chris awesome Chris and you were the
humor the lady the caught my attention
because you were like going yeah I'm
deal bring it this way bring it to mama
so I so what's your name I need from
leads from oh my goodness she's from
lays like awesome so um what why did you
want to come on stage so bad I think
we've got a very good deal so if you're
saying points five eights are why I just
don't believe you that's the thing you
can do you think you can say 30% all day
long
he's always do could you just wash your
hand again sorry I mean I knew could you
just take one of the Pens at the bottom
of the page right in big letters the
percentage of return on investment that
you think your property is getting
because you know we need to see it
written down in it so you can't wriggle
out of it later
welcome to my world
alright so it massive massive loads
right at the bottom of the of the page
how many people does it take they all
three of them gather like right come on
let's brainstorm how we're going to do
this how we're going to write this right
at the very very bottom of the page it
okay so thirty point five eight percent
is what you think the the return on
investment is so Jamie we're going to
get the computer screen on and I want
you to get the postcode already for me
Jamie and let's have a look to see what
we got all right go for it it's TS two
six two nine two six nine a why no and
why sounds like Middlesboro or T solid
its Hartlepool hmm which one is it this
one here all right let's see the
condition what do you think guys
someone said it's beautiful it's
absolutely beautiful
okay let's have a look at the
description let's see what's wrong it's
Freehold that's not bad okay is it worth
fifty thousand I did and I offer the 48
thousand and she's happy for me to come
over and put in the offer but she would
want me to do a viewing yeah um subject
which you said coming to a view in 48
sounds reasonable yes I just called rosy
just in case well we're looking about
550 ish I mean we had we I've been
checking out was sort of looking at the
figures and it is around 550
[Music]
okay alright so by just two magical eyes
it's not pantomime but it's okay so
we're gonna we're gonna you have to
prove that so what's the I'm gonna go on
to open grins because I'll tell you why
I mean five fifth day guys
it's in good condition it's it's free
holes I've spoke to the agent it's still
for sale they've said that they'll most
likely accept Fortier if the rent is
5:50 I mean that will be pretty I'd be
very happy to give you 500 pound cash
tonight you might not want to accept my
offer but we can talk about that later
but I've got a strong feeling that the
rent is not going to be as quiet you
think so well hold on hold on hold on so
this is the house it's a three bed is
the three beds and it's in Keswick
straight so let's do let's do even one
kilometer let's be fair let's do three
beds
it's a mine oh there are some for 550
but there's this one which said it might
not be quite as nice but this is ready
for 400 and it's in the same street and
it's two events
because Oh what are you thinking Chris
so you said the return on investment was
whispers was 13% I reckoned that the
return investor that 400 was probably be
more like what recognized
I reckon probably maybe around 23% which
is still better than my deal but it's I
don't think it's good enough to win
because I imagine a stronger is this
stronger
all right so Chris Chris let me ask you
a question what did you learn in
one two third I love
so if you rigidly return-on-investment
right never look tell me someone have
you spoken to the agent smokes the agent
the vendor is looking to move down south
bought it for 46 K in 2017 I
provisionally got a viewing booked bar
on the provision that I'm only coming up
there if I can get it for 42 K and what
did they say they're booking in the boom
okay so you saying that the vendor
boarded 46 that's good that's good in
2007 it's on 450 but you said you'll do
fifty to forty two and they've said yet
come and look so they're very the
chances are you'll get it before we
choke yeah all right it's two bedrooms
let's see what we think of the condition
folks what do we think of the condition
kitchens dicen needs a little bit TLC
but it's run yeah yeah it's nice I like
that
alright so what's it going to rent out
for three nine five three nine five is
that going to give you the return on
investment that you need yep let me see
the figures of return I don't think
that's gonna figures bring me the
magician please don't let me down man
please I definitely believe that you get
three nine five for that I really do
okay let me just check that you
definitely get that rent man shoosh yeah
yeah you know what look this one's went
in at 400 I definitely think do you
think that 395 is fair do you think that
42 grand from the sounds of it he'd get
it but for each oh so the question is if
you bought it for 42 would you get that
return on investment have you got I mean
I need to I need to get my character out
so someone can follow me along to make
sure I don't miss anything and remembers
the number the numbers that I'm saying
but if you can really get that 31
percent on this then I'm very impressed
so they're just prized 42,000 can you
get a mortgage on that just about so
you're going to put down 29% in total
which is 12,000 180 remember that figure
maybe write that down 12 180 love it the
mortgage is going to be 31 500 times 3%
divided by 12 they said
the eight pound a month so remember that
78 pound a month
78 pound a month
all right let's carry on so 395 I'm
gonna say 400 rent I think you get that
would you agree so times we're going to
knock off the mortgage of how much plus
80 pounds so minus 80 minus 74 actually
78
so it says leaving us with 242 pounds
times up by twelve two thousand nine
hundred four divided by twelve thousand
and and 180 gives us a total return on
investment of 23.8% whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah let me show maybe I'm wrong
three no five minus 74 minus forty for
the for the you got a minus the money
for the maintenance management man hey
sorry I'm so all right so hold on hold
on hold on guys guys is it a good house
what did you learn
what Joe Wade nurse all right buddy
I'm starving
Stephen now did any of you guys know
each other before sure yeah the trophy's
I didn't know what the names are even
now you do so what's your main song so
um so pearl pearl pearl or now there's
no time so what's the name again wattage
you don't have to be smart to be very
very rich
okay what's the postcode whiskey
November 8 yeah 9 November alpha and
you're very confident about this
property yes yes all right go ahead and
write the return on investment then on
the on the on the shape that's the same
property he does the same one yeah all
right okay
[Music]
freehold that's good
three-bedroom property have you writing
the ROI on the board oh just twenty four
twenty four point ninety eight I'm
hearing lots of murmuring what do we
guys think you don't like it it's people
are saying it's sold already but I don't
think it's sold I think that's just the
name of the of the alien it's a good job
they're not on stage all right so what
do we think of the condition guys did
you speak to the agent that's the only
thing we didn't okay it's not the end of
the world I know that you only had an
hour and things like that so not the end
of the world what information have you
got this couldn't how you gonna sell
this to us so we looked at when was the
true market value which is 61 Oh
based on what based on the website we
looked at which was the website
struggling
what was the website that you looked at
my surprise I probably was it just say
it's one 461 so that's fine the RAM much
rent are you suggesting that this is
going to get what we suggested he'll be
as five to five sounds high let's have a
lot so the house itself it was a noise
she was it a two bird three bed three so
it's three Bell is in very good
condition and it looks like that let's
have a look to see on open rent okay
five hundred just then you're saying
five to five let's see what else we got
then 500 I'm probably thinking probably
closer to like 500 there's quite a few
that rented for five hundred but yours
is particularly nice on the inside what
are you guys thinking you got better I
mean I do like it what return on
investment are you saying it is return
the investment we said is the final
value twenty four point nine eight
twenty five I like it I just don't love
it it's like fifty three grand you
haven't spoken to the agent you think
we'll get about five five to five grand
you guys want to go in there what you
want to choose that one
we're gonna go through the super-quick
of ready to go ready cuz we're
what if you people have come up and I
think we've learned a few lessons
tonight yes or no pay attention don't
forget the costs management and
maintenance did you guys know each other
beforehand no you know hu8 so what's
that is it one of these you're very very
lucky this top one or this one
I know if we've got time for this
are you sure all they're saying is this
house you're very lucky
is it good condition guys it's men and
that's your question have you spoken
keep the mic super close to your mouth
have you spoken to the agent or a day
yes and what did they say they said they
are not reducing the price only 50k and
then we can view the house I said what I
think we can view the house and they'll
accept a 50k yes but they're not
reducing they might reduce it they won't
fine so it's on for 50k no problem
what's it worth 45 thousand so it's
worth 45 but that only accept 50k yeah
but the rent is high how much is the
rent 495 they guys aren't feeling it
what do you want me to do I don't know
[Applause]
I'm stuck because the guys aren't having
it I'm sure it's a good house but on
this occasion with regret you're evicted
your arm
alright go gonna say they're gonna say
there was a couple of properties that I
liked the most
one two three I'm yes all right so
standing your team so you can separate a
little bit so you guys what was your
team name again team Lancashire and your
property was was was good I think what
was the as you might work it yeah what
was the return on investment the return
on investment was twenty four point nine
eight percent the thing I liked about
your house was the death felt that it
was quite safe you know you you you it
wasn't amazingly high ROI but it was
quite a safe house and I quite liked it
your property you got I kicked you off
quite early because you just you didn't
know basic things about the property but
what we made an error with the market
value yeah so it was actually more than
what we said it was okay what was it was
sixty seven thousand in Co 45 what if I
was the sold price on 2000 so why do you
think that I should choose you guys
because our etern ROI value was twenty
six point five oh well here's what my do
what she chimney hole lancashire here's
what my dough I'm gonna make one of your
proposal and the person I want to make a
proposal I'm a man who believes in the
power of counsel I think having counsel
wise man has many counselors so I'm
gonna let twelve these twelve hundred
students of mine choose which one so
Lancashire or hall whoever gets the
loudest noise I'm going to make a
proposal to guys like you [ __ ] or home
[Applause]
Lancashire
I'll tell I tell I tell you what when I
put my hand over their heads if you if
you want them to be the winning team
just make a chair so Lancashire all
right
I'm gonna make a proposal to Lancashire
so hall go grab yourselves a sick
all right good well done so Lancashire
here's my proposal to you guys so you
guys ready are you ready ready
all right your house is good it's stable
it's a solid 24 percent it's gonna save
my team time I do like it I also like
Lancashire so here's my proposal you've
got three options and I don't want you
to tell me what your what your option is
just yet until I say so your three
options of this option number one is I
can buy the property off you and I will
happily pay you in cash five hundred
pounds on the spot and then the property
is mine you have no links or ties with
the property whatsoever option number
two is you can buy the property yourself
and you can either do a joint venture on
it or you can one of you can buy it
yourself and you can keep it option
number three is you can wait until
tomorrow and tomorrow we're gonna learn
about how to buy properties on lease
options normally down and you can hold
off and try and buy it tomorrow on a
lease option agreement those are your
three options is that crystal clear all
right now at the crash course we have a
tradition what do we have plays and at
the crash course we don't we don't take
lots and lots and lots of time to think
about decisions because it's that real
life in business no it's not in business
you have to make what kind of decisions
instant fast so we're going to give you
15 seconds to have a team meeting right
ready and your 15 seconds starts now
[Music]
[Music]
ah
and what do you think they're gonna say
if you remember what would you know hi
alright so guys get the microphone ready
drumroll please and tell us what are you
gonna do right what we've decided to do
we had along we've had a chat about this
but what we just said not long but we've
had a chat and what we've decided to do
is we think that we will take the money
but however however what we'd like to do
is we'll make a contribution of our
share some of our share to a charity all
right very good well I don't forward to
find a house
you split between this region take a bow
and give them a hand
very good well done guys congratulations
what a great job great job well done
well done
all right come on
you